john cena is one of the big screens
toughest guys and i mean tough standing
over six feet tall and weighing about
what 250 yeah he's a big boy um he has
muscles on top of muscles and that's why
what you are about to hear will probably
surprise you but it's John's way of
helping others my name is John and I was
bullied as a kid John grew up in a town
where his love for rap and wearing
hip-hop clothes wasn't so popular in
fact he started lifting weights to
protect himself from his bullies and now
he's helping others if you could
confront all those people from your past
what would you say to be yourself
because you are beautiful now this isn't
the first time that we've seen John's
big heart in fact remember his very
public proposal to Nikki Bella will you
marry me
[Applause]
while we're waiting for those I do so
you teamed up with props come as you are
campaign to invite people celebrate
their uniqueness and inspire everyone to
feel comfortable in their own shoes
maybe they see something interesting and
they think that maybe I'm beautiful I
would lose the maybe it's definitely
[Music]